soir olivier marais tôt écoutez bruno le
maire ce matin qui nous disent voilà
finalement le 20 janvier ce n'est pas
acquis non plus quelle est votre
réaction
commencer un petit peu avoir l'habitude
de problème c'est que systématiquement
on a des annonces qu'on essaye de ce
qu'elle est dessus et où un discours là
où on est quasiment tout sûr que
effectivement à la le 20 janvier donc
donc c'est assez compliqué on a on nous
demande de financer ça en plus avec avec
de la tête
donc aujourd'hui on a des affaires qui
s'endettent et le jouerons pas ouvrir on
va voir un volant de dead qui va être
qui risque de propulser pas mal de daffé
l'air vers leur faillite dirais donc on
est ça devient très très compliqué votre
demande ailleurs a été rejetée au haut
conseil d'état c'est peut-être ça le
pire cette espèce de manque de soutien
tout est dirigé selon vous on
l'entendait chez vos collègues contre
notamment un les restaurateurs mais
aussi les discothèques ça on n'en parle
même plus parce que c'est vrai que ça
fait un certain temps qu'ils sont plus
là voilà ça s'acharne
oui puis surtout enfin vous savez nous
on est un moment on comprend pas ça nous
avait demandé dans un premier temps de
mettre en place un protocole sanitaire
ce qu'on a fait il faut il faut
considérer quand même que voulez vous je
travaille 70 heures comme en affaires
est ouverte par semaine dans mon
business minimum 1 g personnes dans mon
affaire
kaka ulcos vides ont tous les verts on
débarrasse on fait tout donc on est on
est au coeur de l'enfer si on considère
que l'enfer c'était je vous à faire
aujourd'hui on est fermé
les chiffres continuent à monter un
moment si on n'est pas un petit peu
l'espèce de 2
de deux modules de d'action du
gouvernement ont fait quelque chose on
ferme et on ferme et on ferme les
affaires donc c'est donc oui c'est qu'on
veut c'est très compliqué on commence à
en avoir un petit peu un petit peu marre
un petit peu plus qu'un petit peu
d'ailleurs alors demain les choses
changent encore il ya plus de
confinement au sens strict mais il ya un
couvre-feu ne nous réjouissons pas trop
vite 20 heures 6 heures du matin ça va
encore aggraver le cadet de la
restauration qui perd finalement la
vente à emporter
cette fois ci tu sais bien ce que vous
savez moi j'ai moi moi je suis fermé par
par exemple j'ai baisé j'ai des copains
qu'on contenter comptant quelques trucs
qui vait pas de vente à emporter l'avant
et c'est pas rentable mais juste pour
continuer en créant un lien à partir de
demain ils vont être ouvert de 12h à 15h
fait non c'est pas rentable on perd de
l'argent ou perd de l'argent toujours ça
nous oblige à faire des de
l'équilibrisme et c'est terrible
vraiment terrible vraiment terrible le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous a
retiré 100 % de nos recettes et on nous
couvrent pas 100% de ce qu'on a à payer
donc je connais pas une personne
aujourd'hui qui si on lui disait sur son
salaire
tiens regarde sortir 100 % que ton
salaire par contre je t'en rendre 75% et
je te dis que je t'aide qui dirait pas à
son interlocuteur mais là tu me prend
pour un con c'est un peu le sentiment
qu'on a aujourd'hui
alors 20 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dans le projet de budget
pour 2021
un premier pas quand même pour vous en
faites vous faites le gouvernement noah
un petit peu tout
on parle du chômage partiel mais si
aujourd'hui on n'avait pas le chômage
passé a été pris en charge par l'état
l'état continuera à payer parce que tous
nos employés seraient au chômage tout
court
il n'utilise aujourd'hui vous allez on
va prendre finalement ils font un pas et
on va prendre finalement les congés
payés sur les veaux mois de fermeture
simplement c'est pareil nous les prendre
simplement ils nous mettent en porte à
faux avec nos employés puisque nous
employer pour être obligé de prendre des
jours de repos par anticipation c'est à
dire qu'on est obligé de on dit à nos à
nos employés aujourd'hui vous devez
contribuer
au maintien de la vie de votre
entreprise
mais les pauvres n'y sont pour rien
comme nous on n'y est pour rien et en
plus dans nos métiers on a beaucoup de
gens qui cumulent un petit peu les
repent pas ce que c'est les villes ils
partent après à moi deux mois à
l'étranger
la de là où ils viennent pour profiter
de leur famille et c'est parce qu'ils
ont des vies qui sont quand même pas
très simple et nous aujourd'hui en train
de leur demander de prendre par
anticipation des congés pour rester ici
juste pour sauver notre entreprise
parce que l'état ne peut pas l'assumer
lui même et ça devient très compliqué
dans le discours même clairement olivier
marais tôt aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous demandez aujourd'hui il ya eu des
manifestations
concrètement que demandez-vous la
réouverture d'autres aides
mais si on n'a pas la réouverture on
n'est pas mais ça on peut pas anticiper
nous on a l'impression qu'on n'est pas
plus dangereux que que le métro que les
grands magasins que les grandes surfaces
même bien moins parce qu'on met des
protocoles qu'on applique un et on n'a
pas assez espèce de flou dans les
galeries commerciales etc
mais à partir du moment où ils ne le
font pas retirer 100 % de nos revenus
mais assumé 100% de nos dépenses
voilà et on parle même pas des revenus
de nous les patrons qui sommes pour la
plupart pas salariés très clairement
donc c'est juste nous on nous demande de
faire des efforts nous demande de payer
1 pour la politique du gouvernement
encore une fois c'est pas nous payer et
aujourd'hui on nous demande même plus
que ça on nous demande de nous endetter
pour survivre mais c'est pas normal
aujourd'hui clairement vous estimer à
combien le nom je sais que vous n'êtes
pas économique c'est difficile c'est
peut-être une question piège mais enfin
vous parlez j'imagine avec votre
collègue vous estimer à combien le nom
deux restaurants de restaurateurs qui
vont disparaître aujourd'hui en france
ou au moins dans la capitale je sais pas
il y en a qui disent un tiers il y en a
et 30% 40%
mais vous savez on a cette faculté aussi
à vouloir survivre
donc on va se battre on va s'endetter et
puis après on va le tampon qui va être
fait ça va être ça va être nous de nos
revenus
ça va être ça va être ça va être tout ça
mais je pense qu'il va y avoir au moins
30% voix qui vous autorise le dépasser
et c'est et c'est terrible merci en tout
cas olivier marzotto d'avoir été avec
nous patron du bistrot chez mézigue dans
le 19e arrondissement merci à vous